the event starts off this hour in
Columbus Ohio
hiya vet how are you what's up hi I'm so
I went to a smart money event last night
on a night I thought of Rachel and I was
super excited I had an awesome time
actually won $250 Wow and I bought the
SPU for my husband and I - I just stated
and when I told him about it this
morning she was really really upset he's
aware that the program is he's brought
on the ones like what's trying to get
that free but I was looking for a like a
fresh shirt and I was wanting to come
clean about a credit card that I've had
that he doesn't know about and when he
freaked out about he hundred dollars I
spent on FPV when I won 250 I was just
really caught off guard and like I don't
really not know where to go from here
okay I'm a little bit confused about
what he freaked out about if you spend
$100 your husband freaks out yeah
because we didn't talk about it and I
have a history of not doing that you
have a history of buying stuff and not
talking about it right so it really
wasn't the purchase of FPU and it really
wasn't $100 it was the action of you
continuing to do things with money that
you guys are not in agreement on right
and he's tired of that right which he
has every right to be and that's kind of
where I got to the point last night as
an event where I'm like you know enough
is enough like this is ridiculous I
don't need to be acting like a child
with money like I need to you know what
didn't you do this and I'm learning to
take responsibility for my part in this
and that's kind of what I wanted to do
today and come clean with them but then
when he was so upset about
just like $100 what she was no no
no no no he's not upset about the
hundred dollars he's upset about your
continued pattern mm-hmm
let's name this what it is okay okay
because because otherwise we're making
him sound like a jerk and he's not he
had a right to be upset because this is
a continued pattern of you guys of you
just doing whatever the flip you want
with money and you guys are not on the
same page and he's tired of that right
okay and I he has every right to be and
I'm not trying to be where am I
like well where my hesitation is because
like I basically I heard you say it
before to somebody else that it's like
I've been unfaithful in the relationship
and that's exactly how I feel you know
and I don't know how to kind of like
bear this out and then well you don't
yeah you're not in a safe place right
now with the relationships what you're
saying
and so if since he this is not going to
go well right now is what you're saying
so and so he I III think the two of you
probably ought to start going to
Financial Peace University but as you're
doing that you probably need to sit down
with a good marriage counselor and you
need to create an environment with that
marriage counselor in the next three or
four weeks where all your cards are on
the table especially this credit card
and and because you're not gonna be able
to go through Financial Peace University
carrying the secret that's not going to
work and every day you carry it right
now it's going to get worse in terms of
his reaction but you've got also got a a
thing here where he's gonna have to at
some point from a relationship
standpoint give you a fresh start and
say okay from today forward we're going
to go okay and instead right now what
he's doing is he's looking at the
pattern and all the history every time
anything comes up which is not it's
justified but it's also not going to
work
going into the future if you're changing
right right right if you're if you're
gonna continue the pattern that you've
done then you're going to continue to
get him upset I mean any and as you said
he's got a right to be on I agree so I
think the two you need to sit down a
good marriage counselor and then I think
the two of you need to go to this class
together you think you can get him to go
to both no because he's he's I've gone
to counseling before and we've done the
marriage counseling before by the way
you see that these are my issues which I
feel like they are - yeah they're not
though I mean they are your issues but
you guys getting your relationship put
back together is both issues both of
your issues right and so we can't we
cannot stay where we are with this
broken trust and disrespect and it's
unraveling right and he does have issues
in that regard whether he thinks he does
or not it's not the point has he done
quote something wrong that he needs to
go to counseling for no that's not what
I'm saying but the two of you have got
to find you've got to map out a process
whereby you can heal this and go forward
and that's not just gonna be oh the
event starts behaving it's not that
simple
because he's gonna have to then there's
got to be some payoff for you where
Trust is rebuilt and the relationship
heals and you move forward and so that's
where you need a good marriage coach to
you know lay out the path forward
between the two of you and so yeah you
need to if he won't go you need to go
see a marriage counselor without without
him because I'm afraid for your marriage
right now I said it's in a real broken
place and I'm afraid that this credit
card might be the last straw
if you don't map it out properly
because it sounds like he's he's at the
past the boiling point on this and so if
he sees this as one more that time that
you have violated this process and the
season he begins to see no hope that
you're ever going to stop
then that's when this is going to be
over and it sounds like it's getting
close to that in his head so you need
someone to navigate you guys through
this so you can stay together in this
process and then yeah you do need to go
to class together and yes you do need to
go to marriage counseling together I
don't I can't make him go though but
you're asking me what I would do if I
were in your shoes that's what I would
do
thanks for the call